ja und hier sind wir jetzt bei inneren
out burger das ist sich lange vom 3
und da drin sind die ganzen menschen
schon fleißig am burger brezel und jetzt
gebt euch hier den laden wird heftig
voll leute dass da leute fast gedacht
und jetzt willkommen bei einem neuen
video ja leute ich hoffe euch geht's gut
uns auch wir sind hier nämlich gerade in
was eigentlich das in den usa falls ihr
das letzte video noch nicht gesehen habt
oder falls ihr es gesehen habt solltet
ihr es ja dann schon wissen und in
amerika ist ja alles viel größer viel
krasser und vor allem auch viel
ungesünder als in deutschland also
dieses viel ist wirklich viel viel viel
egal wo man hier essen geht man fühlt
sich direkt vetter also ist halt
wirklich so du gehst frühstücken es ist
so fettig es ist so viel die klatschen
da alles möglich an saucen raum also für
die leute die nicht hier waren es ist
wirklich heftig und trotzdem haben wir
eine schöne aussicht ich zeige euch das
mal kurz ist auch ganz schön hier geht
direkt dieser heilen
und da hat man dann gleich eine kleine
skyline wir sind hier in beverly hills
glaube ich also schon ein cooles vierte
sieht man auch an den häusern darf
deswegen wir das ding da rein weil das
ist der nachteil von unserem zimmer hier
es ist laut weil die straße direkter
dran ist so jetzt kann man mal auf den
punkt was heute machen und zwar geht es
um burger leben nicht erst ja am
liebsten burger und in amerika ist ein
bürger laden neben dem anderen und es
gibt extrem viele läden die auch
wirklich richtig geil sind dies in
deutschland gar nicht gibt und ein habe
ich gestern schon getestet der hieß in
den augsburger
heute wird der nächste getestet also uns
zusammen möchte dann auf drei kommen ich
würde sagen wie lange man gar nicht
sagen da fangen direkt an breit bürger
lehnen die ist in deutschland nicht gibt
oder drei fastfood burger restaurants
ketten wie auch immer ich wünsche euch
viel spaß bei diesem blog und mit sagen
let's go wir fahren jetzt los so leute
werden jetzt abend und wir gehen essen
und zwar mit dem ersten burger laden ich
hab ja eben schon erklärt worum es geht
und der erste bürger laden nennt sich in
den augsburger der war auch an meinem
letzten blog schon kurz drin habe ich
aber nicht wirklich gefilmt ich wollte
euch jetzt mal kurz das essen zeigen wie
es da aussieht vor allem wie es im laden
ausbildung so weil das sah echt cool
also ein ganzes menü kostet ungefähr so
7 euro und das ist eine kette die gibt's
halt fast nur in amerika geboren
und die ist hier auf jeden fall richtig
guten lauf es ist jede filiale immer
voll egal wo man lang fertig den autos
im drive und so das echt krass ich zeige
ja sofort
naja bis gleich das ist übrigens
überhaupt da gibt's frühstück das wäre
dann eventuell auf seinen part da kann
man so über frühstücks hast du deine
deiner beieinander da bock drauf habt ja
jetzt mal daumen nach oben oder
ja ja und hier sind wir jetzt bei
inneren out burger das ist die schlange
vom 3
und da drin sind die ganzen menschen
schon fleißig am burger prozent also
hier arbeiten wirklich extrem viele
menschen drin
und jetzt gebt euch hier den laden der
heftig freuen
allerdings schlagen
ich bin
am 1
männl
was wir denn jetzt hier cola cola wörter
juli hier gibt es war hier gibt es
wasser
leute man kriegt sie denn sonst hätte
und man muss warten da steht man noch
mal drauf wie bei den moderneren
mcdonald's heute alle nummern werden
hier durchgehend aufgerufen
und es ist sehr sehr viele nummern
wir haben gerade sieben und acht bedeute
dass es da das ist ein ganz normaler
cheeseburger und diese pommes die fand
ich jetzt nicht ganz so geil habe ich ja
zwiebeln drauf mit dem endgültigen
fassung der bürger gestellt
obwohl auch bürger
christie's gebrauch merchandise kauft
euch die sorten
so leute das war's mit innen auf burger
kleines fazit und eine punktzahl ich
vergebe einfach rouladen punkte weil ich
so ein guter bürger testa bin also der
bürger ist mega lecker das problem ist
der laden ist heftig überfüllt und ich
fand es sehr dreckig also so
gesamtpunktzahl trotzdem weil der berg
hat wirklich so krank ist geben wir mal
9 von 10 punkten und mal gucken was der
nächste bürgerladen sein wird wir sind
jetzt bei wendy's heißt der nächste
laden ist aber nicht diese pferde
zeitschrift sondern einen burger laden
vielleicht kann die dinge jetzt einfach
mal rein
für mich immer so dumm
ich wurde gerade sehr springen
aufgefordert hier nicht zu filmen weil
keine ahnung erwarte ich von erstmal mit
dem thomas an besser als in deutschland
jetzt hier den bürger mag aber auch
keine guten
laut bager ist viel besser
ich finde das sieht auch nicht aus oder
bewertest du irgendwie vergleich zu
sagen also leute die kommission echt
geld vor allem mit diesen tipp den gibt
es in deutschland nicht keine ahnung was
das ist den burger fand ich jetzt nicht
lecker ich habe genau nicht auch
wirklich keine ahnung so auf dauer seine
mir irgendwie nicht aber die durchaus
und dann ist das bei mir so dann kann
ich mich weiter ist aber juli schmeckt
so leute wir waren jetzt hierbei war auf
jeden fall ganz cool die
zusammenfassungen die sauberkeit war
ähnlich wie beim auto das war schon er
dreckig auf dem boden aber ist heute
fast food laden die cola und kommissar
den bürger fand ich nicht so gut
die verdienen war ganz freundlich würde
man hier sagen so 7 von 10 punkten aber
nicht neu
hast du jetzt noch weiter zur nächsten
und fragt jack in the box da hole ich
mir jetzt auch noch den bürger dann habe
ich nämlich drei merkt er ist jetzt hier
direkt um die ecke und das bietet sich
an
normalerweise lässt sich nicht so viel
ich darf meine bruder davon aus bringt
also irgendwie finde ich dass ich auch
wieder hand sich aus oder
[Musik]
so leute hier ist mein burger jetzt drin
also eins muss ich sagen ich finde also
auch das one geben oder wenn dies wie
auch immer diese küche sieht so eklig
verdreckt aus ich habe das hier auch ein
bisschen gefilmt ich kann das einfach
jetzt nicht so essen und sagen so geil
haben die ja richtig gut zubereitet
verstehst was ich meine
natürlich ist es bei burger king und
mcdonald meistens genauso in deutschland
aber ich fand's jetzt hier eigentlich
sogar noch schlimmer bei ihnen aussieht
das mega geil und mega lecker aus bei
dem ihr und dem davor komplettes
gegenteil also so was habe ich noch nie
gezahlt
das macht genau das ist wie diese dinger
im film immer
so leute wie haben uns jetzt hier noch
eine metal location ausgesucht mit den
letzten berger ich muss sagen ich habe
gar keinen bock mehr darauf ich hätte
lieber einen apfel oder so also ohne
spart also der hier ist jetzt von jack
in the box ich habe keine ahnung
vielleicht gibt es auch noch kleinere
läden nur das war jetzt halt so die 3
die uns jeder gesagt hat dies halt hier
gibt so als kette und in deutschland
überhaupt nicht
sieht ganz gut aus
naja ok ich probiere kurz
das wirkt gar nicht nach bürger künftig
wird das brot ist hier richtig geil aber
das war's dann irgendwie auch willst du
mal probieren ein
sollte wir gehen jetzt noch zum dorf
street market oder da nehme ich euch
noch mal mit jetzt jeden also jack in
the box ist okay wir es selber solaris
mit ihm her hier gibt's ja schon im
spiegel muss das denn hört wie wir sind
jetzt hier zurück im hotel hatten noch
einen coolen abend haben was gegessen
mal wieder die welt entschuldigt ist
geil
wir machen das nicht gut heute ist hier
zum ersten mal dass die betten gemacht
wurden im anderen hotelgäste gemacht
heute ich habe mir gerade hier socken
gekauft für 20 euro sechs paar socken g
20 dollar kann man sich auf jeden fall
nicht beschweren und 2018 sehen dollar
auf jeden fall ist mir aufgefallen dass
ich gar kein richtiges ende gefunden
habe eine sache ich habe am anfang noch
gesagt es ist krass das innen out burger
so gut schmeckt und da muss auch
wirklich sagen in einem auf burger ist
das einzige was ich euch hier empfehlen
kann geht am besten dann immer dahin
bevor er noch was anderes ausprobiert
weil dieses handys und jack in the box
wie auch immer das ist echt nicht lecker
das hat so eine komische qualität das
hat mir überhaupt nicht gefallen das
ding ist in der laut burger das gibt es
hier nur an der westküste und mir wurde
gesagt das liegt daran weil ich darauf
achten dass die fleischqualität
möglichst frisch ist und das fleisch
nicht das wird jetzt irgendwie ein
bisschen krank
das fleisch darf auf jeden fall nicht
älter als 72 stunden seien und es wird
gar nicht eingefroren deswegen soll das
wohl besser schrecken kleine ahnung was
selbst dran ist also in outdoor rat von
mir neuen punkte bekommen wenn dies gut
gemeinte 7 jack in the box sagen wir
sechs also es ist nicht schlecht aber es
ist halt weit entfernt von gail leute so
viel bis hierhin ich habe mir das video
hat euch gefallen es macht spaß hier in
las vegas niveau los angeles wir gehen
wollte auch noch nach las vegas deswegen
morgen geht es aber erstmal einen
freizeitpark den freizeitpark es ist
einer der größten achterbahn tags der
welt darf ich auch richtig bock drauf
dann mache ich auch im blog von da kommt
dann sogar morgens schon online leute
ich wünsche euch was sein
jackson abschied und snake instagram
abbekommen coole fotos das war es von
mir